unfortunately I think there are some
people who still believe that I wish I
could say that that is an idea that's
completely gone and and nobody thinks
that way anymore but I think if people
would be completely honest there are
those who still think that and and all
you have to do is look at you'll see
people still picketing with those kind
of signs every once in a while and it
really makes me angry and I have to say
that I sort of fit into that category
for a long time I part of my ignorance
was I didn't realize how big it was I
didn't understand how big the HIV
problem was and the part where I was
just absolutely wrong was I thought that
it was a gay man's disease and in my
view at that moment was that excuse me
for having to care I was so wrong I I
mean I was completely wrong and as I
began to study and research I realized
first of all it's not a gay man's
disease more women and men are infected
around the world but I had to do some in
in religious terms I did you some
repenting I had to do some apologizing I
had to I had to do some I cried a lot of
bitter tears at my own hard heartedness
because I don't think that's God's view
at all I don't think that if you look at
the pages of Scripture Old Testament and
New Testament God is clearly tells his
people to care for the sick clearly over
and over and over he tells us to care
for the sick and when you get to the New
Testament you you just won't ever find
Jesus asking somebody so tell me how did
you get sick what did you do did you put
yourself at risk did you do anything
wrong that has led you to be sick you
just won't find it you'll find Jesus
always saying how can I help you
and so for me the repenting and the
changing of my of my mind and my heart
was to say first of all the guy god I
haven't represented you well I haven't
even understand understood your heart
for people who are sick so I'm sorry for
that and then I usually start most
conversations with people in the HIV
community both here and around the world
with an apology and and I just say I'm
really sorry please forgive me I I was
wrong I've not been present I've not
encouraged other people to get involved
and I have a lot of making up to do
and it's really cool because everyone
said well I'll find somebody that says
yeah where are you then you know where
have you been
but most of the time I am given such a
gracious response where people say that
was the past you're here now and that
humbles me you know because justifiably
people could really you know beat me up
verbally and and have nothing to do with
me and while there are a few most of the
people are just like we're just glad
you're here